welcome to another fantastic episode of
riffing with Griffin I'm your host Eric
Griffin and as usual you know I'm still
looking for a theme song I've have some
good ones recently but I got a good one
another one tonight from my good buddy
cow quiz mundo I sent another banger
but let me introduce my fabulous guest
speaking of bangers mister Russell
Peters is here everybody so anyway this
is a new theme song again by calchas
mundo you sure you saying his name right
I'm not sure from city looks with a Q
quiz mundo Quiznos
it looks like Quiznos but it's whatever
but do you make money as a DJ when I do
okay but you but do you make money as a
DJ because you're Russell Peters more
nor more so because of Russell Peter
okay I'm fully aware like so you like
Paris Hilton no no because I can DJ like
people I think initially hire me because
I'm Russell and then they find out I can
really rock a party and they're like oh
[ __ ] so Vijay
so were you DJing back in the days where
you had to carry the crazy start doing
an 85 oh man my buddy Marvin he's the DJ
and I and I had to carry crates oh I
know all about I used to tear up the
my car with that [ __ ] and then my
fingertips would get all [ __ ] deep
real DJ's know you either the skin on
your fingertips gets all ripped up
because you flip into the records trying
to get a song out paper cuts and the
rate of the record the lip of the record
would record like the record [ __ ] case
would just click click click click now
how did you stay on top of like because
in those days you had to go out and get
like the 12 inches is all you would get
records Wow and did you like how did you
stay on top of it
if Thursday's is when new records would
come out so you had to have your eye on
what was coming out yet to know when
release dates were and when hope hope is
a banger know you had to know you had to
just know you had to have your ear to
the ground imagine there's no internet
there's no like it was just like
word-of-mouth backed I was like yeah how
would you hear such as such and then
they're like the radio played this song
last week like do I get that song and
then they would go into the record so I
remember looking for the 900 number by
the 45 King and I didn't know what it
was called because it was an instrument
a nananananana oh yeah yeah yeah and I
remember one of the records turn like
it's like something to do with horns I'm
gonna mansion and cuz I got this record
feel the horns I go let them let me hear
that and then he put on go that's not it
and who would've known was gonna be
called a 900 now I'm lookin at some
funky horns maybe I don't know I'm like
thinking of names it could have been Biz
Markie was the one like I thought was
the first like famous dude who then went
into DJing and they never looked back
biz is like musical genius like when it
comes to knowing music like biz knows
everything like he's a kind of he knows
like the the liner notes he can tell you
liner notes on anything really like oh
yeah record yeah so-and-so played drums
and this guy from another plan played
sax on that one and I love that kind of
stuff yeah and this has like so much
[ __ ] that nobody has but biz is a
hoarder he won't give you [ __ ] you know
everybody yeah business that got the biz
has um these these turntables that are
look exactly like twelve hundreds but
they're specifically made for 45s
so the platter isn't a 12-inch planets a
four it's a 7-inch platter yeah but how
does the does it record no no the record
it's it's like instead of being full
sizes this size Oh
nobody has him only he has them and he
won't tell anybody where to get them
like and I mean anybody like Jazzy Jeff
I was like Jeff why don't you have those
beers won't give nobody nobody I'm
pretty sure he had from some of that Yo
Gabba Gabba money I remember going to
another good one is was it Kate Capri I
remember going to a Def Jam taping yeah
and I've never in there now it's like
the new stuff now so now he's using the
computer and all that no he's still
using twelve hundreds but he's using his
laptop right right he loses laptop I
mean that's what I'm saying
using a laptop of music but I've never
seen a crowd go from zero to like after
after what he was doing that you're just
like you know ok another level of party
rockin yeah that's like let me tell you
that guy he's he's sweating I'm
surprised he hasn't electrocuted himself
that's the way he's dripping over the
mixer and stuff and as a DJ like me and
I like you watch him and he's so hard on
his mixer you know he's like the whole
[ __ ] shaking and I'm I'm more of a
finesse guy I'm like that good it is
this still a thing I'm still a thing
it's still very much a thing how often
are you doing like what are you doing
parties bar mitzvahs like I plan the
house more than anything
oh your daughter is hiring you I know my
daughter wants me to get off the
turntables like daddy let me DJ oh wow
she doesn't do anything but hit buttons
you know I'm like okay and dad to get
back to this yeah but that's like you
know you're just in a stadium you know
just you're just pressing a button and
you're like hype and everything what I
do that we don't do that you know you
know so when's the last time you were
paid to be a DJ and what was it a few
months ago 15 20 grand or something like
that oh wow yeah I didn't ask for the
money amount so yeah it's like it's good
money
yeah it's hella good money and it's for
me it's like I love doing it yeah it's a
challenge because it's like let me look
at these people because I can't go in
with a plan I'm like I can't be like
here's what I'm gonna plan if they don't
like it too bad I'm like no I'm a real
DJ you got to go in and go okay I'm
gonna go for that I gotta I have to go
this way with it and then if I want to
go that way I got it I got to slowly
sway them back that way now do you
pregame with like playlists do you have
like no I have all my music on my left
okay okay and so then we never lock my
crates on my laptop
oh sweet so you have your crates labeled
like and it'll be like 80s 90s gotcha
80s hip-hop nineties radio whatever and
as your playlists I mean your your
crates you can or you can hit all and it
plays all yours it shows you all your
[ __ ] yeah but if you want to save time
and you know if you know what direction
you're going and you just click on your
crate and you go through it well that's
what I'm saying so you're like at this
you're at a party and you see the
whatever it is and you might decide oh
this is an early 90s hip-hop crowd yeah
so you change it up on yeah you don't do
it I didn't see this is like it's like
doing stand-up you're like okay I saw
when I do this set and you walk in to go
okay dick jokes it is you know I mean
like it just like dick jokes to a DJ is
having to play like overly commercial
music oh it's the worst you're like oh
that way do you have a crate for that
it's just like you don't say commercial
[ __ ] yeah Bieber's in there everything
you don't ever play on your own until
your daughter's on the car too right D
is your daughter hip or are you my
daughter likes really sake are you are
you taylor swifting in the car oh no no
I don't let her listen to [ __ ]
III play my music and then I wait for
her to react to it and I always changed
the lyrics to every song and sing it to
her about her like I literally like a
song when I was make up a song and
she'll sit there laughing smiling and
enjoying it and then her mom gets mad
she's like she doesn't let me sing and
go cuz and she's like my daughter cuz
daddy makes up songs for me yet she
doesn't know the lyrics that you're
changing these haven't changed all right
you know we're skipping ahead we're
skipping we're skipping past all you
stand up now we go back it doesn't have
to be I like to flow because it's like
what I like to do on my podcast is I
will I'd love getting people's origin
story because okay my fans don't know
and it's like so you're from Canada born
and raised Toronto won Grammys in
Toronto beat down throw it up and it was
from Brampton I'll tell you some
Brampton let me know other people from
Brampton director X you know a little
extra music music acts I've known him
Julian since he was 12
Julian it just takes away from director
yeah it just takes away from it
Michael Sierra's from Brampton well that
makes sense Tristan Thompson's from
Brampton
auto players are from from that's got
Thompson's from Brampton
I don't know Tristan Thompson was a
Canadian yeah he's Jamaican oh [ __ ] and
that other kid Anthony Bennett who plays
basketball is from Brampton 200 but he
was the worst yeah I don't know I don't
know anything about basketball but yeah
I knew Tristan and I are friends oh oh
I'm that kid everybody yeah that kid is
very popular as a rapper he's from
Brampton to that kid who's very popular
that's a rapper he's who Drake I don't
know you really you really coming across
as an old-ass man oh I don't know that's
man because I don't know these young
kids he's very popular too he's you know
he's got big songs it'll come to me he's
got we'll think about he's decided to
start beef with people and you're like
don't do that that's not the world for
you buddy just be a rapper
oh is it somebody okay now I'm now I'm
when I wonder who it is let's Google the
[ __ ] if somebody did something Oh
nobody's life ya know in that life she's
over there
well forget about that so you're you're
from Brampton as I would just call
Daniel 20 minutes outside of Toronto 20
minutes outside of Toronto and then you
started doing stand-up very early there
were 30 years now that crazy 30 this is
your 30th year I was 19 she started at
19 in Toronto you Danny Yuk Yuk's was
young I think that it was luck has been
around since the 70s yeah Yuk Yuk's when
I started Harland Williams had just left
and come to the States and he was
already on his way to being a big star
already and Nour McDonald was already
gone
Jim Carrey was already gone everybody
was already on their way and I was I
started the funny thing to me when I
started in 89 it was like right as the
boom had ended all right so I got to
deal and I was 19 I was a young kid I
didn't I know buddy my family's in show
business I knew nothing about show
business and to me as far as I was
concerned I'm not in show business I'm
doing stand-up right right right yeah
yeah yeah my own like stand-ups not show
business but stand-up just started to
get on TV to like all these little crazy
little show yeah an evening at the
improv and Friday night comedy comedy on
the road
John Byner and then there was all these
Canadian versions of it comedy at club
54 oh wow and all these little you know
rinky-dink shows but it was all it was
all important to the process now were
you a person that we like do you fill
out you were the one of the few people
of color
I was those people oh my god yeah
especially from out of Canada I was the
first Indian guy yeah there was guys
it's tried it before me but never stuck
with it you know they just did an
amateur and I called in an afternoon
after that but that was it I did it and
I was like miss all I'm gonna do I think
well your parents disappointed they want
you to be a doctor or a lawyer or it
wasn't in the cards for me they knew
they knew you were dumb from John no my
parents knew they were like you schooled
them yeah they're black kids they were
like you're not look at your friends and
I'm they were just like he's not the
scholastic my parents would literally
beg for me to get 50% on it damn good 50
oh well you could call with your parents
yeah I think yeah I'm saying were they
supportive like when you did you tell
them hey I want to be a comic and then
you went out yeah they had no clue what
it was oh they didn't know I wasn't
gonna be a comic like okay that's fine
the day come to shows when you were my
dad drove me to a show once and I think
I'd only been doing stand-up maybe a
year at the time we're driving home
because I didn't have a car or a license
I think at 20 even and though my dad was
like son you need to expand your
repertoire here the other guys they were
talking about different things keep
talking about this that's going to get
one-trick pony
well that's hilarious that you're like
immediately he's giving you advice about
how to be a comedy read Reader's Digest
they've got some good anecdotes on that
so how how long before at 19 how long
before it like it became something that
it was like oh I'm actually really gonna
do this I gave myself an eight year
window eight years Wow I said I'll give
this eight years and if an eight year
has haven't done anything then I'll jump
out of it I was think of gold because I
was like and by done anything I mean
like even like making a living even a
[ __ ] living yeah yeah yeah yeah and you
know by the sixth year I had
I had my first special oh wow and a well
then what happened before that though
like on the road working yeah yeah yeah
you wanna really just go he's like oh
yeah Russell you shouldn't sleep on my
couch to sleep on Chris Spencer's come
to sleep on Patrice O'Neal's couch yeah
yeah I've been since couch yeah that was
a couch surfer yeah I didn't know money
I was broke gonna do come to LA and just
get a hotel I don't kind of like that
yeah so you own a New York hotel I
didn't have it like that and I drove to
New York from Toronto it wasn't like I
flew in it was like I'm gonna sleep on
your couch like a go yeah you the
boarder do all that said that you had to
pay for parking yes I'm done with some
in a nightmare but when did but when did
it like when did he click when was it
like when did you know something special
was happening
I still didn't ever really know
something special was happening really
yeah it to me it I'm still in my head
I'm like still waiting but you would say
okay okay that's a whole other
discussion right but you did some
YouTube videos right or you guys you put
your standup I didn't put it on there
okay someone put your standup on youtube
here's what happened yeah I need a shot
a special in August of 2003 mm-hmm it
was my third special rip your third
special yeah yeah three specials before
or 95 97 and 2003 what was the 95 one
that was the first one it was like 22
minutes and always a half hour it was in
Canada okay okay and and it was sketches
too so as maybe you know 14 minutes of
stand-up Wow and and then the rest was
sketches and it was great and it got
nominated for Canadian Emmy oh wow all
right and I thought that that moment I
was like ooh something I'm on to
something here yeah because the CBC got
flooded with fan mail at that time and
then they got complaints and they're
like this is how you know you're doing
something yeah yeah well like you and
people hate you yeah you were right you
were right in the middle yeah and
they're like congratulations we got a
complaint letter go and I was thinking
oh my god is this my end my end of my
career like no great it is yeah
because again I had nobody guiding me
there's nobody in my family there was I
didn't have any like like friends and
nobody was successful all the people in
Canada weren't successful they were all
just angry comics I was around about all
these bitter dudes did your parents get
involved at that point
they weren't even excited so you're
nominated for an Emmy yeah
Canadian Gemini akinator Canadian Emmy
but I love how you just like it's like
it like it means nothing and I took my
mom to the Gemini Awards is my date oh
that's great and well that's that's huge
though
yeah but again at the time I knew I
didn't belong I still you know the whole
thing with comedy is you're an outside
yeah yeah no insecure from jump yeah and
and you never deserve anything yeah and
even though I'm there and I'm nominated
I'm still treated like an outsider
nobody knows who I am nobody knows why
I'm there and I'm like so I'll be at
that time - one of the few guys of color
even in a build oh absolutely
yeah and still to this day I feel out of
place yeah yeah and it's hilarious when
I go to Hollywood parties and people
ignore me I'm like yeah that's that's a
whole thing funny find interesting about
you this I find is so interesting
because like you've been on the Forbes
top ten list of highest-paid comedians
for like five five or six times in the
last like ten years and you could walk
into a room and people act like like you
know they go oh okay we can't do
anything with you yeah yeah and it's
like what are you talking about yeah I
think you got to stop taking a person
along you know but but but you first do
you it breaks your [ __ ] heart
but when okay alright but go back you do
that special you do another special do
another special two years later which I
was not ready for okay
this was now cuz this is now it's an
hour yeah because now it's an hour and
it was right after I'd done that so they
were just trying to Bank off the
popularity of the first one and I wasn't
ready and you know that's in 97 I told
me to in stand of eight years I didn't
have the chops to write that quickly or
I didn't really know who I was onstage
yeah bless you thank you very much
since my baby left me so uh yeah I
didn't have the chops I didn't I wasn't
really deserving of that second shot but
you did you feel that way then or were
you like a little arrogant no no I kind
of felt that way at the same time but
they offered me 10 grand
oh yeah now is still Canada mm you still
rate D like I had the standard special
for 10 grand and then I got a some sort
of holding deal from somebody for like
like 85 like and at the time I'm like I
just got ya what did I do
yeah I did yeah we bought a [ __ ]
Lexus or SH I did of course you did I
traded in my Isuzu Rodeo it was a used
yes three hundred black with tan leather
interior and had the gold package so all
the letters and numbers were gold Oh
Mike come on 97 what do you want from me
well you are you are a pimp all-in son
so you've spent all your money on a
Lexus yeah and then I would got to a
point where I couldn't afford the
payment but you put down how much did
you put I have no credit you probably
had to put down 10 grand I put the car I
don't remember but I know it was more
than what I should have been doing and I
remember about a year later was 98 and
uh and it might have been that same year
and Chappelle was in Toronto shooting
half-baked right oh wow and I'm hanging
out with them and I'm like I feel like a
dick now and I think about I go Dave I'm
having trouble paying for this car I'm
kind of hinting hoping he'd go yeah man
let's break down what you need right and
I go man this car is killing me goes I'm
short on my payment this month just
hinting right he goes maybe I shouldn't
have bought a [ __ ] Lexus and that's
your first lesson right there now I
really got a hustle on pay for this car
because that motivated me to go I will
not lose this car oh good for you
yeah I'm not quit so the second special
you make 18 grand you lose it all on ten
for the special 18 for eight and a half
for something else but it's all combined
it seems at the same time yeah so did
you ever follow through with the holding
deal like no I don't ever happen to that
this is somebody can still hit you up
would be like hey man we have a holding
deal with you back in 89 and 90 77 a
holding deal so then you did that
special on how did that well how was
that received it was it was okay
Tammy and I don't like it it's [ __ ] if
you watch it did you see it it just
stand up no even I watching oh that's
horrible and what I'm wearing it's
terrible what I did was terrible it was
trash and it deserves to be mocked if
you do see it if you do see it and like
it we're gonna love me now so then I go
from 97 to 2003 no special six years and
at that time I'm throwing ready yeah
yeah I'm really working on my act
working on me I'm working on everything
and I get this act together and now the
same people who did the 97 sputters hit
me up in 2003 oh you want to another
special I'm like yes please and they go
$7,500 and I'm like wait wait you gave
me six years ago
what is this deflation what the fun but
I did it anyway yeah because I was broke
when I say I was broke Eric how broke
were you I've got that check for $7,500
right I just signed the back and gave it
away cuz it was oh [ __ ] to get me out of
debt oh man and I was still in debt but
less I was 7,500 always less and did
right but that's but that's especially
blew me up oh okay but there's all right
so you did that special did it blow you
up from the plate that plays on TV so it
no here's what having an aired in
February 13th 2004 right
and it got a nice response it was
received well and then in Canada yeah
and then March 15 2004 my dad passed
away mmm
and that was like [ __ ] well at least he
got to see the special you know right
and then after that I guess somebody had
recorded it and then chopped it up
because I you know did my jokes about
different nationally top my group
Italian Chinese Indian Jamaican they all
chopped it all up and then it started
getting sent around in file sharing
groups which I didn't know anything
about that world and thought and then
for you at home file sharing groups
means he was going viral I was going
viral before we knew it viral was before
we even knew what it was and and that's
on YouTube not YouTube YouTube didn't
exist yet no what was it it was just
fight with like groups like oh I oh I
see what you're saying yeah yeah you
know right and it would probably take
you two days to down yeah audio galaxy
you know sting their share bear yeah
yeah they're sharing they used to be
like my er I used to be like it would
take like days to download like six
songs yeah and you were thinking to
yourself oh my god I'm beating the
system yeah now you can download like
Prince's whole album on your phone
unless that is like fun so that gets
sends around that gets enter so here's
what here's here's how I knew something
was going on because that same night
that it aired I was in DePaul University
in Chicago and they paid me $700 to do a
show there and only 11 or 12 people came
out that night and I felt horrible
because $700 is a lot of money yeah it
is a lot of money that's a lot of money
but they don't care those cows don't
care no but I didn't know that I'm yeah
yeah yeah I'm a family right yeah but
I'm like and I feel passionate giving
their money back yeah I mean like nobody
showed up but did you give the best show
of your life yeah I killed it and this
is how I know something was happening I
went back to Chicago in November of that
same year and sold out some theater
tapes and I'm walking with like 30 or 40
grand and I'm like what the [ __ ] just
happened in this house and I couldn't
quite figure it out but when people
meeting me like yo you know can you sign
and I'm like what what are you talking
about yeah we got this burned
disk of you this DVD like people were
like passing around burnt my DVDs of
this baby they were ending in you and
then in June of oh five is when YouTube
started and then it just went through
the [ __ ] roof yeah that's okay so
that that particular time was when you
knew but I don't know who uploaded it
all you still don't still to this day to
that person who deserves a check that
person again they are happy meal
otherwise somebody has to hit you up and
been like you don't know but anybody
could you know I was the one what if
they have proof what if somebody give a
pretty violent proof what would you do
they prove I would buy them something
very suppose your generous coyote yeah I
mean I'm not a dick well I'm I'm a dick
but I'm not selfish ride as a dude
distinction there so then you blow up I
mean and I can like really blow up
though like this I mean take him viral
to another level I mean yeah do you that
was the HIV of comedy at that time yeah
man yeah you were its patient zero I was
and then you but damn but then but then
it was like but it was worldwide
worldwide
it was worldwide and then like the next
thing you know you're like you know
you're actually like you know almost
like you're in the underground you know
I'm you know it's gonna outskirts of
Hollywood and making like so much money
yeah I moved to I moved to Hollywood in
2006 January 2006 and I had a big-ass
house in the hills and well to me it was
a big-ass house because I was living in
a townhouse right right right
1,500 square foot town house that my
brother and I lived in right so anything
with my bedroom you know I'm like I got
three thousand and you know I bought
this house in the hills and and from the
from the backyard and from the going up
the stairs you could see the Hollywood
sign in the distance and I was like oh
my god didn't say I would literally have
I would wake up I don't have dreams when
I first moved out here because I didn't
know anybody I would have dreams that I
woke up and I was back in my bedroom in
in Toronto and I was like and it seemed
so real oh wow and then I was
my guy was a good dream and then I
remember I went home once or twice in
that time right and I woke up in my
bedroom in Toronto and I was and I
realized and I thought that the LA thing
was a dream and was like aha because it
was all the same [ __ ] I had left it was
exactly the way I left it so I was like
oh no oh no [ __ ] me this is real life
so you're not accustomed now you're in
your house your big house hmm
well yeah you know I get it and you know
things are happening your your people
know who you are you're traveling around
but now it's just a moment though that
you felt to yourself because that wasn't
your dream your dream was still that you
at this point your dreams to be in
Hollywood right you know what my dream
was always just to make a living and
stand up like this is a completely
different level of living that I
couldn't have imagined like it's not
like and from stand-up yeah and like
only solely from stand-up is there's
nothing else made giving me money you
know I mean so if I don't - I don't live
well you live it I'm living I'm living
okay yeah you're doing all right
things are bad yeah more one time I said
to you I said it was just what it's just
what money feels like and you said you
should fill my black card feels like
nobody looked at the camera for that so
how do you um but then I I always felt
like did you feel a certain way about
like not being accepted by Hollywood
yeah I well at the time I was I felt
guilty at first initially I started
feeling guilty nothing you know you're
talking about explain this you're
talking about what if you started making
money and and all this attention I start
felt guilty because I was like but wait
there's better comics than me there's so
many better comics than me that deserve
this position more than I do and we
would go into meetings back then and I
all I would talk about is the color
comics that needed this more than me you
know and they don't care about them we
want to know about you and I'm like but
I I think I really may have talked to
myself out of the game at that time
because we'd leave these meetings in my
agent my brother might who's my manager
but I was lucky doing supposed to be
talking about you I can't talk about me
it's not in me to talk about me like
right right so it became a thing with
her like you're not stop talking about
other comics who's better than you they
don't
we don't care who [ __ ] better yeah
that's like it in a relationship that's
a good sign felled episode where you
keep the month at one with area and a
girl you know the George is telling the
girl like I'm you're too good for me why
are you with me then eventually you just
start to go yeah maybe I am too good for
you yeah I think this we have won
Hollywood they were like yeah you don't
deserve it
yeah yeah basically I wouldn't be
surprised if that happened you know
finicky this business is so finicky so
yeah that that happened and then in Oh
seven is when I decided I was gonna try
and do an arena I said alright let's
let's do the Air Canada Centre in
Toronto where I'm brothers like are you
sure because you know we could do the
Sony Center which is like 3500 seats or
something
you could do that maybe you could do two
nights I'm like I want to try something
different I was like I really wanna make
a statement
I wanted you rent it out yourself yeah
we did it ourselves yeah and I was like
I just want to do it I want to see what
happens and we got a promoter involved a
guy that we knew who was actually we
still work with him he's a great guy
Howard hair Harold love and great guy
and um and I said let's just try it and
my brother goes well if it doesn't sell
we could scale it to 8,500 and you know
one look is unsold out tell me because
how many seats 16,000 Angelo tsarouchas
was with me when we put it on sale we
were in the Middle East somewhere and we
get a call we get a call like maybe
about two hours after went on sale
saying it sold out I'm like what but I
get sold out I go how many 16 thousand
seeds ago they want to add a second show
huh
so we added a second show it's sold out
right away - it's like what the [ __ ] is
going on and then they go we want to do
it in other cities so we did Vancouver
at GM place I think it was called back
then and and that was 18,000 seats and
that sold out two nights - I was like
what the [ __ ] is going on
you still didn't know I still didn't get
it it's still the register you say that
you say that right but there is part of
you that knew no no the part of me that
knew but there was there's still that
part of me that was like this is
something's wrong here this is the happy
you were testing the limits rice has to
be a false reading or something like
somebody's [ __ ] with me right
all right and then the first night when
I walked out on stage in Toronto you
know the lights go black in the in the
venue and they started screaming and I
started getting teary eye but chin
started quivering I'm like [ __ ] I'm
gonna have a breakdown I'm not gonna
make it through this and I walk down
this gave me a standing ovation they
were just screaming and I'm like I'm
doing this [ __ ] I'm like I'm like all
right get together buddy so I had to get
it together had no choice you got it
together huh and then like so then that
the rest is history after that night
because that was the moment that like it
went from like it went from like okay I
think something I think something's
going on yeah to like oh [ __ ]
something is for sure going yeah and
[ __ ] everybody else I'm gonna do this
yeah and then I thought okay that's
that's one time the the [ __ ]
sensations gonna go away people gonna
get bored of me and it's gonna be all
over but at least I got to experience it
right right
then a no.9 we did the same arena thing
two nights sold out everywhere again I'm
like huh and then in in 2012 we did it
again and then in 2014 we did it again
and and then 2016 we did it again
and then just now I did it again and I'm
like oh what the [ __ ] is going on like I
mean it's just something but it's not
these nights anymore now it's one down
to one night guys
oh you failure well that's great though
man I mean you just like how does it
feel like to know like you know that's
to be so loved
well you know what it is it's just I
think my fans are very [ __ ] loyal and
I will never not give them a reason to
not be loyal because they they're
consistently coming out for me mm-hm and
I have to consistently give them a new
and good product and right so if I was
[ __ ] this up and [ __ ] in the bed on
these tours they wouldn't be coming out
and right right right but that's not the
case but you also put on I put on a good
show and you also bring good people with
you yeah I want great calm yeah yeah I
want guys or girls that are gonna bury
me I want you to bury me before you
before I go on I want them to go Wow
Oh bro so is this good because this
guy's incredible yeah yeah yeah a gun
this - I had Jason call
opening for me and he [ __ ] murdered
before I went on you know Jason arias
yeah I like [ __ ] and then I had Jake
Johansen on the tour with me earlier
last year - oh wow and Jake's a legend
you know as a guy used to record
watching him on TV and again you know I
wanted people that were gonna really
bring it not once if you had me on your
tour but we're too big oh my god yeah my
size has movies oh my your great it you
can do a date if you want you say this
all the time you know that III but I'll
do it no you know you say this all the
time and then I come later you go how
you know I double booked this I do tend
to do that I still owe in Edwards days
yeah God and Ian is [ __ ] yeah I want I
want I want the famous watch I know you
give people you want to get to watch
anyway yeah I hear oh I hear about all
this I don't have a watch on us I did
golden watch no no they don't get a gold
watch or whatever it's not that it's not
it's not that highfalutin no but you had
a joke or you had jo koy back in the day
I'll call you back in the day yeah yeah
I'd yeah we did we did some good ones we
did a tour once it was me Gabe gabriel
iglesias Lisa Lampanelli and Steve Byrne
and I hosted it Jesus cry in a headland
I go no I want to host it
so I hosted then Steve it's so Canadian
of you then Lampe and then Gabe Jesus it
was fun yeah that sounds like Hulu
followed that when I run this was about
10 or 11 years ago before they even like
yeah they were in the ground floor yeah
yeah yeah mark Morgan Spurlock did that
now when you um at what point like
you're doing the theatres now your big
[ __ ] you're feeling it you're feeling
yourself mmm no I'm not you still not
feeling yourself as you've done ladies
hears that they've done a theater tour
and more than once arena [ __ ]
you've dinner you're doing arena tours
you're selling out to Knights as someone
you had to be like I need to get to
Hollywood now I need to I need a show I
need a movie in my head I was like can't
you see these numbers Hollywood doesn't
this mean anything to you yeah but they
didn't care and
for whatever reason it didn't click for
them I think the thing that they saw was
that I was successful and then they were
like we need to we need to bank on that
success and which was great but then
after a while they didn't if they if
they don't get it
they're not gonna get it see what they
were trying to do to do with you they
were trying to be formulaic with me and
I'm not formulaic at all what they would
look to me what they were trying to do
was use what they're trying to do with
these YouTube kids now these YouTube
kids don't need Hollywood right they
have everything they need they don't
realize it mm-hmm but they still think
they need you I want to be in movies I
want to be in this it's like no you have
20 million followers and you're making
millions of dollars outside of Hollywood
and Hollywood sees that and they're like
we got to get some of that mm-hmm and I
think they were trying to do that with
you we've got to get some of that but
how yeah they didn't know they did it's
funny because they would say oh I love
your stuff and you're like really
oh when you do the accent yeah yeah yeah
yeah we could put that of the show or
now they were so say will you do the
access I got them really do the accents
any more talking about it yeah but [ __ ]
it you know but you just did a great you
had to get the show in on the Canadian
Network right which one the Indian
detective was on Netflix two was on
Netflix but did it start on it was it
was initially through a Canadian
production and then netflix bought it
okay Netflix said we want a second
season if we buy we want a second season
I was like that's great and then came
down the second season had like man we
don't want it like what and then
Canadian Canada was like it was the
number one show four weeks in a row it
got high it was like in the millions of
viewers which in Canada is a lot of
people because Canada only has 30
million people afore Nia has 30 yeah
yeah yeah to have millions of viewers at
that point every week was an incredible
deal and then when it can--it got
nominated for awards and won awards and
and then candles like now I can't afford
to do it anymore
I'm like what so even though you win
[ __ ] win okay so then it just went
away
yeah this goes away I'm like whatever
but we're gonna do something with it
we're gonna turn it into a film oh there
you go I mean but that's all gonna be in
done independently like whatever you
know
I kind of look at it this is my process
this is my way through the game my way
through the game isn't gonna be led by
anybody else I'm not gonna have people
going hey we want to do this with you
it's people go yeah yeah but that's how
you did it anyway with the Twitter feed
with the arena's like that anyway yeah I
think you mean they need somebody more
malleable something they can create
because if they create you they can take
you down all right but they don't create
you how they gonna tear you down or
they're not giving you anything to tear
down for me or take credit for it yeah
like I can't get on any late night shows
why not
I don't know but I don't care anymore
cuz I'm like yeah how can you part of
you care as part of you doesn't you're
like how is that for you how is that for
you to be in like a Malibu mansion you
know you got five six cars in the garage
you know you got a lot of money you're
on the Forbes list but there isn't there
are still a part of you that's like damn
it I can't get on a late night show yeah
I think that bothered me for a while but
it doesn't bother Benny right yeah you
seem to be I'm 49 years old they're like
yeah I got to worry about them ya know I
got I got I got two kids I got I got
[ __ ] to worry about I can't be worried
about my ego anymore my ego get takes
has to take a backseat when did that
start alright so it's a new it's a new
minute it's about it's like a year old
so you go you you you the landing gears
out in 250 you're just gonna be like you
know I think I need to stop being a dick
yeah it's it was you know for me it was
like I'm gonna it's eating me up yeah
and I'm like why am i letting this eat
me up no but by the way I completely
understand
it's almost a crazy thought to be like
I'm on I'm in the top five of Forbes and
you telling me that I can't this is
literally people I literally put you on
that list dudes are fans that watch TV
look at me I'm all I never got to do
Letterman yeah
and that's the one that really broke my
heart because I ruined
letterman back in the day but I never
got through Letterman but whatever I did
Leno once I did Kimmel twice and you
know Kimmel is always nice to me and
Leno's always nice people a nose not on
the air anymore but but Kimmel is always
nice to me and I don't ask I don't to
ask anymore right right you don't want
to be the guy that they look at and I
want to avoid because you're gonna ask
him for something huh so you learn to
just take it as if they want you they'll
come get you if they you know otherwise
be happy with where you are be happy
with what you cut and you know Conan's
people tell me I don't fit what they're
trying to do when I can come on do
stand-up I go I don't know yeah what
does that mean do you not want like I
don't know what the [ __ ] you're trying
to yeah but whatever you know I can't
again what am I worried about this just
just deal with it think good things are
still happening yeah that's what I'm
saying that you're a [ __ ] fool if you
sit there and focus on what you don't
have instead of what you do have yes but
it's a weird thing it's like it's such a
weird to get into the entertainment
business it is all about trying to
achieve something and then we lose sight
of the things that we've already
achieved trying to achieve this thing
that might be unachievable but also who
gives a [ __ ] right it's uh it's a it's a
poor way of looking at life so yes and
and how do you feel bad for a guy like
me you can it's [ __ ] impossible to
feel bad for me yes I never no no I mean
like I stopped I literally have the
ability to step outside of my skin look
at me and go [ __ ] you yeah I'm [ __ ]
ungrateful dick yeah like if you're not
yeah you're in the park another commie
store talking about Comedy Central won't
even take a meeting and if people like
man you just drove up and the $250,000
car yeah I know well that's the honor
that's what I started doing I started
looking at everything and going did you
ever imagine any of this would happen no
then what the [ __ ] are you mad at you
[ __ ] ungrateful Beast that's good for
you that's I mean it it is a revelation
like a self realization where you got a
you know you just got to change at
certain age it is 45 and it's hard to be
like this is who I am you're never gonna
change yeah you've got you gotta you
gotta make these steps if you want to be
happier in life so when you started to
like really like you know money money is
like not a issue anymore
did you do you have a big family it was
it a thing where people will know it's
just my mom my brother myself also you
get used to that
easy to keep it tight yeah no extended
family nobody hitting you up I mean yeah
hit me up [ __ ] everybody got it that
I tried earlier [ __ ] I wish it was
alright I literally got hit up three
times a day by people that aren't even
that [ __ ] close to me I'm like yo man
hey cuz now I'm an empathy I'm an empath
so you know if I see another human in
and they're not doing well I need to
know how I can help you but at the same
after a while but at same time I'm not a
[ __ ] idiot boundaries yeah and I'm
like alright like if I can see that you
need help but you're not asking I'll
help you but if you if you're blatantly
just thinking I'm gonna be the guy I'm
okay so if I come to you about my Lexus
payment now you're that guy basically
and I'm like and everyone asked for
outlandish amounts of money you know
it's 20 grand man it's need 20 grand I
go wow that's I have a lot of people and
I'm not I'm not rolling like that no but
you like but again I mean I get but
people people have this perception you
know what I mean yeah like they you know
they always come to me with their things
like business ideas and like I got this
idea yeah I got just thing let me holler
at you about this thing and I'm thinking
to myself like what do you I was on
basic cable man like what do you what do
you think's happening right now time to
I had I went I went from basic to
premium - yeah you gotta streaming yeah
yeah okay I gotta go streaming I gotta
get our network but yeah it's amazing
how many people have these like weird
money problems and you just go hey man I
used to do it like you're saying yeah I
used to sleep on a couch I used to sleep
on couches I know what it's like to be
broke I know what it's like here's the
thing I'm 49 years old I was broke for
the first 35 years of my life
I know broke much better than I know
what Wow and and but I like money yeah
yeah yeah but it's also not never been
my driving force in anything and that's
why when I get these kids kind of me go
I'm doing stand-up for Yuri's you know
yeah okay you want cue much I said and
give me some tips on how to excel all
right I go for years yeah what like what
do you what do you - I could blow up
what what does that mean yeah don't do
this if that's your goal it's like when
people come to me and they go hey man
how do you how do you get in at the
Comedy Store
and when they say that I just get the
[ __ ] out of my face yeah like it's like
asking somebody like hey man I want to
be a neurosurgeon can you get me yeah
it's like no this is a process yeah and
if you don't know that I don't want to
deal with you or when people ask me hey
man could we don't do movies um I know
what I forget to roll up on the movie
sets and tell me what do you mean why I
don't do movies hey hey where's my roll
got some movies movies I mean it's it's
whatever it is you know just honestly
Eragon I'm in a different place where
I'm really just I really like the way
things are yeah like I I all I ever
wanted was the the respect from my peers
which I feel is growing mm-hmm and it's
funny that you say that even even now
you still even now you don't feel you
deserve it yeah I mean I but I would
appreciate just to know that they're
glad yeah you know I think you know may
not be my kind of comedy that I like but
I can appreciate what you do and I see
that you work hard at it you know that's
all I need to know that you you pay
attention yeah or if you think I'm funny
even that makes me feel even better than
I ever say I always say I would say like
if somebody's not my cup of tea
but I can still sit back and be like wow
somebody's drinking this tea yeah yeah
you know you may not for me but I get
why other people yeah yeah I can
appreciate that it's hard to I still
enjoy comedy yeah I sort of wine
you know which is like a weird thing
when you're a comedian you know I mean
cuz it's like I can't watch somebody
special I find it weird because now
you're so entrenched in the game that
you know the guy already or the girl and
you know and you've seen them working
out there's material so you're like
that's cool you just want to see that
you just want to know they made it to
where it's gotten to yeah I know what
you mean oh my god that's good I hope
you're promoting because I'm happy for
you but I'm gonna watch it yeah some of
my good friends is like I remember
watching one of chris d'elia specials i
just turned it on to see and I was like
oh I'm in know our right now you know
yeah you know it just it was like the
same kind of thing and I was like oh
good for him that he's capturing that
that's it and I was like I don't need to
see this anymore I've seen yeah I know
yeah I get it good for you
moving on to me Sebastian's [ __ ] you
oh my god right and
and I'm fighting for him for the Forbes
list now I wanted to beyond I wanted to
win I love watching people win there are
people don't get about me cuz I want the
more people that win the less pressure
is on you yeah
so when Sebastian is winning right now
if I can love it I text him all the time
like congratulations really yeah he's
doing great man I saw him last night at
the India war yes but he was on stage so
I just but I laughed but that's the
great thing about like what's going on
at the Comedy Store right now it's nice
saying it's [ __ ] ridiculous yeah like
it's like this like a renaissance like
we were talking about earlier it's like
here we are at this time that it feels
like it we it may not be as great of a
rise as it was in the early 80s mid 80s
like there's like 70s too early to mid
eighties we're living in that right now
yeah it's a weird something's happening
credible if you get to get a chance guys
you got to get out to the Comedy Store
and watch what's happening right there
and then also with the rise of
podcasting you know he was some of these
people that we see on the walls right
now you know all right P Brody and you
know like Bert and Bill you know Bobby's
podcasts he's he's blowed up
you know re yeah I mean it's it's
amazing what's happening and it's all in
the dollar they got a huge podcast
because they're almost there on the wall
here at all things comedy I'm not even
on the wall
yeah it's outrageous wait you're right
there why I mean you're on the TV they
changed that you know I mean don't talk
about so I know you like to fight I know
you're a fighter and I like to fight I
just know how to fight yeah well you
know you know one night we both had
fights the same I heard about that at
the same night that was about five six
years ago yeah you you somebody punched
you tried to punch you at the Laugh
Factory though and I got attacked on
stage at the Comedy Store I was at the
same night yeah I was at the Laugh
Factory yeah and two guys were talking
[ __ ] to me while I was on stage which is
fine but you know it's the difference
between haha [ __ ] you and [ __ ] you yeah
they [ __ ] glare at you there's two of
them and one's a big guy shaved head big
[ __ ] muscle guy and I'm like what did
you do and I'm like huh and I and I used
to box and I trained jujitsu so I'm like
really
and I'm like if I wasn't angry and I saw
that big get on my [ __ ] with him but
angry bro son go [ __ ] and so I get mad I
walk offstage the club comes up like I
sorry about those two guys they were
being disruptive all night they were
drunk causing problems we kicked them
out on a black eye but I'm you know so
heated yeah yeah so I wait about 15-20
minutes for them to leave and I'm like I
gotta get out of here so I go to leave
and you know when you're leaving the lab
factor you go down that aisle and the
big dude is standing at the end of the
aisle
leaning real at the wall as soon as I
someone pop right in his body and as
soon as you dip down I put him in a
cross collar choke coupe and I put on my
palm I'll [ __ ] choke the [ __ ] out of
you is that when you know you made a
mistake no that's when I was like no
that's when I knew they made a mistake
and then I walked outside and the guy
that was doing all the talking was
sitting in the security guys chair as
you walk out the club so I didn't see
him I walk out and I'm standing there
because I'm gonna go get my car and taps
me on the shoulders like no hard
feelings huh and I was like you my god
and I cracked him but I didn't like the
way I hit him cuz I used to box right
and that day I was sparring earlier in
the day so when I was sparring we were
working up a hook off the right hands
with it wow wow so you had to hit him
again yeah so I didn't like you're a
monster like this the punch hit off the
crowd which bothered me cuz I'm like oh
you should have been asleep with that
person like like you should have been
asleep if I hit you with that punch so
then I did that I didn't like it I turn
into hook Wow I hit him right with a
left hook and then his teeth went
through my knuckle oh man it cost me
money later was it worth it yeah it was
yeah but see like I say you train right
you're doing the Jiu Jitsu what are you
what are you doing now are you still
just digits
kind of dangerous like no I'm saying I'm
saying like I'm talking about like you
could get injured though no you can but
that depends on where you're training
and who you're training with them oh
they know you're not like a like you're
not doing this for because
get the [ __ ] on that a UFC fight coming
up okay they know you're doing this
because you love the art of jiu-jitsu
yeah like I want to learn it and and
master it it's it's a wonderful thing
and I just I started boxing I mean I
walk Cena said oh man it's such a yeah I
mean I box such a runner's and and I
went and boxed in December at the
Goossens gym I trained with rookie Funes
one day and I didn't boxing about three
years and I'm really gonna [ __ ] me my
hands yeah when I first started doing it
I was like my knuckles my hands my
forearms my elbows are like I can't do
this no more boxing's not for me homeboy
I love the sport but I can't do it
anymore so you're saying that boxing is
more taxing on the body say than
jiu-jitsu absolutely Wow
yeah you could be a jujitsu master and
there's a there's a man in my gym named
Yoshi he's 73 years old older japanese
guy he's and he's a black belt he trains
every [ __ ] day and he will tie you in
a pretzel like that yeah I think that's
the next thing I want to try you would
love it yeah I want to try to co-opt 22
pounds doing GG oh [ __ ] yeah while you
were doing it every day I do it every
other day every other day yeah I would
have done it today but I didn't have
time because I had to do so much other
[ __ ] today right yeah I need to I'm
trying to find though I'm trying to get
everybody in at Bert Bert and Tom want
to do it and Steve Byrne wants to try it
I would love to see Bert doing they were
in a group chat they texted me today
Bert Kreischer and Tom Tom Segura they
were like I want to train like next week
and then Tom's like I'm not in town till
the week after and I'm like well just
come through Bert I'll take you with me
it's [ __ ] great do you go to like a
specific dojo I go to Jean Jacques
Machado in Tarzana Wow and he's one of
the best to have ever done jiu-jitsu in
this world a lifetime well that sounds
expensive
oh it's not cheap it's definitely not a
cheap sport but it's worth it I mean for
your it's you know what it does it I
don't know if you have trouble focusing
but I have trouble focusing
and I think most comics have a very
significant amount of ATD in them yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just saying
because you could constantly think you
constantly thinking and when you're
doing jiu-jitsu have no choice but to
think of the person on top of you oh
[ __ ] you're like well if I don't focus
on this I'm gonna go to sleep
do you smoke weed no yeah cuz I'm
starting to think about doing like CBD
ah I smoke the CBD before I go to bed
now
no see I'm don't you smoke is that you
have a vape pen vape pen yeah see I want
to do they know Gino no you know Gino
he's at the comedy store all the time to
speed in that speed weed guy Oh little
guy good dude he gave me this pen with
some CBD oil right and he's what's the
ratio though was it like eighteen one
okay so it's 18 I guess CBD in one THC
right or something but and I'm not a
weed guy on any yeah I mean either but I
don't get high from it at all
and I hit it he said just hit it twice
you should knock you you should have a
good sleep but I've been hitting like
four or five times now I'm like because
I think I'm doing it wrong
I dude and I don't know what you're
saying I'm like I had some I had some
spray they said just two of these but
like I was like you know what give me
three more T's you do it right you know
but I was thinking about like yeah I
feel like I need I'll tell you what this
CBD [ __ ] has done for me though and it's
only been a few weeks that I've been
doing this in the pipe everything hit
the pipe every night every night I I saw
that I sleep better yeah but you wake up
in a great mood every day now see that's
what I mean and I think that's really
been helping me be more level-headed
about life and and that literally has
encouraged me to not be worried about
other people's [ __ ] successes right
cuz that's what I would do before I
would I would fixate on what they're
getting instead of on what I have and
I'm what they're getting they should
they should get something why can't they
get something too
that's just crazy that you're it's crazy
how that were that way they again you're
in a big old house yeah and then you're
looking and you're just like in a big
double king bed going this [ __ ]
yeah why do they pick that guy you can't
be like that this is terribly you're
like Jeebs bring in some caviar terrible
way to live yeah think I'm gonna take
this other side of [ __ ] I don't know
yeah because we're in the students let
me see what we're at where we at Oh see
look at that look at that
we're almost done slow Sun yeah so the
yeah I wanted I want to
can you show him so he can like he's
trying to flex sorry guys are just
fixing my shirt Tommy boxers Wow cuz
you're pulling and you're framing and
you're like all your weight is here so
your core core yeah it's all your head
no that's Rogan about this on this app I
rolled with Rogan a couple of weeks ago
yeah he's a monster it's like rolling
with a [ __ ] gorilla yeah man he's
just a minor black belt in ghee and
noogie no and and we're rolling ghee and
and and my teacher was his teacher so
our teachers they're like my teachers
want to talk Eddie Bravo jujitsu oh wow
and any time any taught Joe jujitsu as
well so Eddie Bravo doesn't exist
without John Jacques Machado uh-huh and
Eddie Bravo is a [ __ ] legend in the
game right right he's not he's not like
sort of he's a very big deal yeah and
rightfully so
right right right and Joe was no [ __ ]
joke on those mats dude and Joe put me
in a move called the twister I'm a blue
belt I'm not he's a black belt who's
been doing this for over 20 years I'm a
blue belt who's been training for three
and what's the next belt after blue
brown purple rather oh [ __ ] it goes blue
are you gonna keep going do you want to
get a bike absolutely goes white blue
purple brown black oh [ __ ] and then once
you're an elite guy you get coral and
then after coral the most elite is red
and it's a red and white belt coral belt
yeah it's black and red oh [ __ ] I di I
would not know our teachers of coral
belt everyone in the world and our
teacher has one hand what yeah it's
gonna got a hand in a hand a thumb
what happened to it was born with like
that and he'll grab you with this and
you're like hey man some guy is like hey
me Wow well I'm scared to try it no no
no you don't get beat up you don't get
beat up - you're an advanced guy well
that's when you start getting when they
know you know moves they challenge you
then because they're like we want you to
start using these moves
so we not we want to know that your
brain is going would do this right here
do that right here when you don't know
anything not gonna do anything it was
like beating up a [ __ ] civilian so
have you have you had to use jiu-jitsu
in in in life yet you've had to be fed
some had some incidents oh man you know
last year funding of last year's in the
Philippines and on tour and we're
sitting around this lounge after the
show maybe my whole crew some local
comedians from Philippines from Manila
nice guys and everyone fifteen of us
sitting around this lounge you know you
know a couch and two armchairs in our
section Warren I'm literally at the end
of the couch I have my drink I'm not
talking to anybody outside of our circle
I'm not being an elitist so just like
you know yeah there's another you're
fifteen people with there's another
section yeah there's no section people
there every was doing their own thing
I'm now you know I'm not out there
trying to pick up chicks I'm just having
a good time driving a drink with the
guys
and I don't see this happen but some guy
walks past one of the guys in our group
who one of the local filipino comic guys
huh and he had a beard he was kind of
chubby nice guy but this guy apparently
rubbed his face like rub rub his beard
and walked away oh no and then one of
our guys goes you know that guy he goes
like no cousin why'd you let me touch
your face goes I don't know any problems
okay no I'm sorry I don't see that
happening cuz that's happening there and
I'm kind of sitting on an angle this way
kind of like looking at the dancefloor
and then that same dude walks around and
comes around to me uh-huh
and I'm sitting there and he's like hey
he look like Russell Peters and I'm like
and I he's standing above me so I'm like
yeah yeah it's true and he goes I do
look like him when he goes and I go hey
I go how you doing I put my hand out and
he goes huh
get the [ __ ] out of here but it was a
weird tone right and I'm holding his
hand now know that Williams shaking his
hand but did you were you thinking he
was saying get the [ __ ] out of here I
can't believe it's rough that's what it
initially seemed but his tone was
completely off with it oh he said there
was a get the [ __ ] out of here and I go
actually now I'm not going any
I'm holding his hand now my gosh I'm not
going anywhere because what are you
doing your [ __ ] what did you do
to him and I go and I could tell by his
tone and a look in his eyes that he was
a [ __ ] so I go you know funny enough
I'm here [ __ ] your mother tough of
course I'm still holding it there make
it worse I'm still holding his hand
right yeah cuz he's talking to me like
he's gonna intimidate me and all right
no I don't give a [ __ ] and this because
you think cuz you're standing up and I'm
sitting down you have the advantage you
are [ __ ] wrong because that's the
beautiful thing about you I'm sitting
down I'm at the advantage not you
alright cuz I am like no it's not gonna
go down like that buster so um so I'm
holding his hand and I'm holding his ham
I'm holding his hand really tight now
right because I'm trying to cope
controlling him now and I'm like and he
goes you're a really firm hand shaker
and I go yeah was that hit that's
probably the moment you thought maybe I
shouldn't know so I go yeah I do Jiu
Jitsu and so he'll be like maybe I shut
up and walk away right and it goes
I do Jiu Jitsu - hey good and I swear
this is the [ __ ] dumbest line of
dudes ever said to being out in public
goes let's see who has the best jujitsu
it's like so I literally without
hesitation I grabbed his arm pulled it
through my legs up and put him in an
armbar right and then and then he tried
to fall forward
and the city tried to fall forward I
kicked him right in his face and then I
kicked him in his face again and then
the security dragged him off and in heat
so he's outside he's on the [ __ ]
ground his face bleeding his glass is
broken
well you Jiu Jitsu better than him and I
and I never got out of my seat I
literally never got out of my seat I
literally did this the couch turned
around and went where's my drink
and it was spilled because this [ __ ]
spilled it well hey yeah yeah you you
won that one you out jujitsu Tim it was
so dumb though but I'm how are you gonna
go bother people and then I just [ __ ]
I'm sitting there with a bunch of people
nothing I'm not looking at I don't know
you now is it out there that you like a
fighter and that kind of thing you feel
you getting more chicken I feel like we
roll game is getting challenged all the
time are like an idiot if you challenge
Rogan let me just tell you that but
people I think I think that people think
they want to you know trying to say they
see him and they're like
take him yeah you know [ __ ] huge
mistake yeah yeah he's just a very he's
a very athletic human being yes he's so
yeah he's like a little muscle man he's
uh he's not the guy to be trying to find
out with yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know you don't you don't want to walk up
to him saying that [ __ ] and then he
seemed to be a measured man though I
think Rogan is also very assertive in
he'll tell you I don't think I think you
should get the [ __ ] out of here right
now right whereas I'm not a
confrontational guy like a man well you
are a confrontational guy only what I
get why I'm just yeah did you challenge
me I'm like hold on a second oh my head
it registers as cuz I dealt with bullies
my whole life so I was like wait I even
in Canada yeah that's why I started
boxing oh wow I was bullied to be Indian
in the 70s and 80s in Canada was worse
than being anything else it was
literally the lowest form of human being
you could be Wow and we were treated as
such and people fell no way and
literally they would say thing adults
would say to kids like I had a grown man
to spray me with the hose tell me to
[ __ ] off and call me a [ __ ] and I was
five years old and I was a cute
five-year-old and I didn't know what was
going on this is a grown man yeah we're
the family and I'm like what like they
felt nothing towards you like view our
little subhuman so it doesn't equal that
they're doing this to another person it
equals that they're just wrecked it so
like a [ __ ] roach let's get rid of it
oh so that's how you so when that
happens to you from such a young age
from the age of three I dealt with that
[ __ ] so from that age to two now it's
still there it's still in your head when
people treat you a certain way you go
yeah I probably deserve that and prom
yeah I'm problem you know I mean it's
been like that since I was a kid that
has I have to be worthless if if that's
how I've been you know I mean so it's
it's it's an it's a continuous cycle of
psychosis it [ __ ] with your head yeah
and that's why you got to learn how to
get past it you can get angry you could
hate white people if you wanted but what
[ __ ] that gonna do yeah so at 49 you
feel like you're finally coming over the
hump yeah I mean I still have sense it
from people sometimes but I don't deal
with it the same way I
would have before and that's kind of
like yeah I remember being in Prince
Albert Canada Alberta yeah yeah yes in
Saskatoon Saskatchewan yeah it was like
I you do this [ __ ] show in Saskatoon and
then you had to take a Greyhound bus to
Prince Albert are you doing I just I I
cuz I'm from LA this was like I don't
know how many years ago ten twelve years
ago yeah because I I didn't think I
could be a comic in LA because I was
like you know I'm from LA so you go to
the clubs you like how do you get on
there I was like I need to get out of
here to learn how to do this so I would
do those type of gigs I remember doing
it Prince Albert in this bar and I don't
you had to go upstairs and it was combat
so you got to see how [ __ ] they treat
Canadian comedians and it was combat
comedy man I'll never forget it it was
the whole show was just like [ __ ] you
you know and then you're just going you
know making fun of people with your
mother you know and everybody's just
like but it was in a way that I kept it
on a balance where people were like yeah
and then after they're like yeah you a
great man
after yeah the rowdiest table in the
whole [ __ ] place yeah they'd go ahead
comedian come over here and I'm like ah
[ __ ] yeah I get over there they're all
cops yeah I'm gonna have a drink with us
all of them were cops yeah because there
was only this prisons and paper mills
but anyway the reason why I'm bringing
this up is like at the time they were
talking about how they were having their
there was a lot of tension between with
the Eskimo community up there whatever
whatever natives the natives and hatton
this is the thing the issue that they
were talking about like how the natives
are being treated and you know they
ended up dead and all this kind of stuff
yeah it's a it was it Canada's racism
associate back in the day was very it
was in your face but we also hit it
really well yeah I was about to say
because Canada Canadians always want to
come across like because I think we
don't care about race and we're like
we're the and say oh no there it's there
but I mean it's you know it's not it's
not as it's not as what's the glamorized
yeah we know it's wrong like in Canada
they know what's wrong so they don't you
know glamorize it like they do here in
the States
what's next for Russell Peters man
continue my deported world tour we go
back out in May and I'll be I got dates
before that obviously but in May with
back international gun the middle-east
and I got India and I'm shooting my new
special in India oh [ __ ] in Mumbai
that's growl yeah is that what your
family's from my dad's from Mumbai my
dad my mom's from Calcutta oh wow but
when I say my dad's from Mumbai he's
actually from a village like about eight
hours
inland like from like when you say
you're from Toronto you really from
Brampton was actually again like me I
was born in Toronto and my dad was born
in Mumbai but then they you know they
moved to this railway village in the
middle of nowhere where my dad literally
my dad's born 1925 so he literally his
whole family were hunters oh sure so
they had to hunt and it wasn't like
you're hunting [ __ ] hell you're
hunting tigers and leopards and all
these dangerous animals and we I yeah he
was a big game hunter so you excited
about I'm very innocent I'm very excited
I always love going to India but it's
like what I mean to do a special it's
like do a special is he more incredible
for me because it's kind of like you
know I made a career out of making jokes
about being Indian right and now I want
to go and celebrate my motherland with
my people and show the rest of the world
that yeah it was just jokes they're
great [ __ ] people yeah yeah I like
that man that's great I mean I you can
you can mark something long enough but
you got to show respect yeah like look
here's why I make fun of you it's
because I love you very close to my
heart now is this like do you feel like
this is like a nice cherry on top of
everything like you almost if you go in
full circle I do when you started you
know 30 years in the game and I round it
off with a special in any I think it's a
[ __ ] beautiful thing I completely
agree man listen I thank you for coming
on you're a great dude and I see I see
you going on your journey still I can
feel it I feel you go you're still going
on a professional and emotional journey
can you tell everybody what I always say
to you when I see no I'll tell them
every time I see Erica go Eric just keep
constantly with this man I'm racially
ambiguous man I'm from all your like an
ethnic Groucho Marx yes from everywhere
you know say wherever I'm with if I'm if
I'm if I'm in like if I'm with Puerto
Ricans they did a porno recap on Mexican
anything I'm Mexican Jewish people think
I'm Jewish
Arabs think Arabs
I'm Erin you know if I'm gonna eat when
I was in Egypt they were like good
Egyptian you know everybody thinks you
know tell no that Sphinx yeah and now if
I go to India to be the same kind of
thing Oh welcome home so I don't know
does it matter
I look like Drake's father you know I
mean it's all I know he I got him yeah I
want to play Drake's father on a sitcom
one straight figures out that he's he's
like ten years away from being on CSI
Miami you know everybody will never have
to do that he's so he's a great kid do
but yeah but he likes to he does he
daddy loves ya I want to be as bad in
something like an great kid he lives in
my neighborhood yes he of course he does
I've known him a long time it's just
genuinely a good human being okay when I
see him or talk to him next though you
know Griffin would like to play your
father you please okay you heard it here
first guys you know with if it happened
it's gonna be because of Russell Peters
and because I peed it but the real money
is kids oh yeah you gonna be there uh
yeah they see how just produce my
Russell Peters what happened but anyways
we're gonna wrap up thank you for her
and now we're wrapping up yeah kid
coming in two weeks now I'm wrapping
yeah you have another kid coming yeah
that's right so you gonna she gonna have
three kids - two - OH - my second kid
okay we got a boy coming oh wow you
excited about that oh yeah
yet 49 you're like oh I gotta start this
over
you know what happy well on that thank
you to the new dad the fantastic he's
finishing off is he's not even finished
with his career but this is a nice
cherry on top of everything that has
happened he's doing a special in India
good way to look after that yeah good
way to celebrate 30 years is to go back
to India where you belong but anyway
this is Eric Griffin riffing with
Griffin and thank you for listening once
again and
I'll see you next week